Okay.
Oh,
exciting platform.
So I'll dress for the weather,
getting degrees in La 15 and Columbus.
We've got a very special guest in the studio this morning.
Joe Rogan.
What's up?
Joe Just showed these people,
these lovely people.
One guy.
One Cop.
The worst.
Yeah,
one of the worst that I've ever seen in my whole entire life.
Yeah.
Oh
yeah.
I'm doing stand up,
uh,
at the funny bone tonight and at the southern theater tomorrow night.
The southern theater tomorrow night I'm actually filming a comedy special for a
spike TV.
Okay.
All right.
You guys ready for the headliner?
Fuck yeah.
You might know.
Has got from news radio off beer back there.
He's head because one hour is bachelor for Spike TV.
Tomorrow night.
Just dug a theater.
Please get off meds or Joe Rogan.
I me mine.
Right.
Yo,
what's up?
What's up?
Columbus?
The fuck is going on my friends.
So I'm very excited to be here in Columbus.
I'm doing a spike TV special tomorrow night.
So it was nice to have that warm upset in just loosen up,
get all the kinks out,
get rid of all the nerves and just the next day.
I just felt
fantastic.
That's true.
Yeah,
but like what is he holding?
He's holding.
I don't make a bell.
Said Hey.
Right back up.
Work.
You broke.
It just stopped working.
This toilet is too low for me.
Every time I go to wipe I hit the water.
I feel like Jack Lab and stick.
Mike,
you could go up back again.
One more time.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hey,
can we,
can we speak English?
Are you going to go around?
We got to be one.
A real path again,
so this is a perfect way to stop.
Stop here and you're in the right spot.
Yeah.
Okay.
Get
Hollywood exposed.
No,
just had to tell Joe that we enter the car three times.
Bruce Lee,
Jackie with a guy,
he's going to fall and he's going to stay with you so we have to drive around
again.
It's going to start with you.
One person.
Joy.
What happened on the plane?
There was like a cop or something.
I wasn't no
little cub.
It was
chill was twisting.
I took the thing out.
I took the thing.
The first class did a little fish.
Mine was twisted,
so she put the meal down.
So he's 12 and his little buddy,
oh my God,
did you see?
And I go,
excuse me,
excuse me.
Nancy's going back to squish the party.
I'm like,
excuse me?
And the guy heard Joe joke,
it's like large county can get cute.
And I go,
excuse me.
I finally just push the fucking thing.
Push the fucking thing off.
It's Bush and the Goddamn meal you're trading.
That was the end of that show.
I ate my meal.
It was eating a meal.
Nerman to have a too.
So she goes up closer to the back of stretch to bring them back to things from
the bank,
taking them up.
She picks up my track out a peaker Tracy.
It was a weed and my ball sack though.
Fucking you kicking me,
right?
I could smell his kicking.
The breadth tab is going off.
I ate two cookies.
I got to go to the bathroom.
I got a pip.
I come back at him and his buddy of
down just tonight.
Hope is there a problem?
What's your fucking problem?
Next time you bang,
it's going to be a prompt.
He went to get up and turn.
He got up,
I grabbed the stove.
I just pull them down here,
just looked at it with a little sandals.
He'd go,
he ran to the store this and he's like,
you know,
he hit the thing and I go,
no,
what's your fault?
Because you put the deal there were actually,
excuse me,
you to fucking look at.
You know,
Yo Yo yo yo
everybody in Ed.
I got off the plane.
He goes,
Amy is that Fuck Police Street concent took me to the one side,
the kid to the other side of this.
This was no alcohol.
It was not either.
See what I go see him.
She goes,
no.
Who was the one you want to do?
They put us both together.
I use my fucking attorney skills.
So the last thing we see in this open is planet earth with you shooting towards
it.
And your logo sort of left in the air.
Sort of like a smoke contrail and the title of the show is sitting over there.
I would say Joe Rogan comedy special talking monkeys in space long before you
start.
Not too long if the bar is taking over [inaudible] 15 yeah.
So rowdy.
Cause they're all
prom.
Warren,
Warren.
It's going to tell it to send off.
They
don't even know what the fuck in there I going to.
Was it still the fucking book you,
I'm saying they don't even,
you're like me now.
I'm in the mix is right.
86 old was the end for Joey Diaz.
Yeah.
Positive Mitch Video.
That's what this place,
world headquarters world headquarters is.
Ignore that this is the motherfucking man.
He directs all the UFC wired's he directs all the UFC,
he directs the UFC.
He's unleashed all that bullshit.
Anything UFC all access.
This is the fucking guy.
And also directing my spike TV program.
Mr Joe.
Yeah.